lignières en berry c'était plus de 3000
habitants au 19e siècle
aujourd'hui la petite commune n'a plus
que 1500 âmes et pourtant elle devient
de plus en plus attractif pour certains
grâce à ses deux moteurs que sont le
pôle de l'âne et du cheval et cette
institution les bains douches avec son
festival l'air du temps petit retour en
arrière sur cet événement avec le maître
des lieux
[Musique]
l'idée de base c'était le départ quand
on était quelque chose a créé
l'association au départ en 1978 c'était
de se dire que il se passait des choses
dans les villes en milieu urbain c'est
toujours le cas qu'à la campagne on
trouvait pas ce qu'on avait envie de
trouver nous en tant que jeune et donc
on avait envie là en fait de prendre un
peu modestement les choses en main et de
faire en sorte qu'il se passe des choses
aussi sur notre terre et dans notre
territoire rural plutôt dans le domaine
socioculturel un peu une façon mjc on va
dire avec tout de même parce qu'il y
avait cette salle de cette salle ancien
cinéma qui était désaffecté depuis
quelques années avec quand même l'envi
rapidement de les proposer des
spectacles au début des spectacles
théâtraux musicaux un peu tout
esthétique confondues et puis rapidement
c'est la musique et en particulier la
chanson qui l'a emporté c'est ce qui
nous motive et le plus ce qu'ils me
passionnément et pour cette édition
comme chaque année la musique commence
mal des enfants de lumière sont sous les
projecteurs
[Musique]
n
dès le lendemain matin ou qui des jo
dans un gîte une longue journée commence
très content de t'avoir se plie ce petit
endroit pour nous figer tous liés à la
tranquillité on n'est pas dans un truc
qui brassent dès le matin moi j'ai ma
tranquillité du matin hier après midi je
suis voulu me reposer un peu j'ai pu
travailler un peu les morceaux pour ce
matin
[Musique]
guillaume est le fil rouge du festival
son marathon commence quelques minutes
plus tard à montlouis à côté de lumière
une promenade chanter dans la campagne
berrichonne qui arrive dans un cimetière
conter fleurette aux belles âmes damnées
ce rêve d'encore une amourette
je rêve d'encore mange du poney encore
une fois dire je t'aime encore une fois
perdre le nord
en effet lyon le chrysanthème qu'est la
marguerite des morts un peu plus loin
qui homme continue la balade en chantant
son enfance bercée paris s'est marié
c'est moi la seule vendue châteauroux
je remplis les vents ces jeux vidéo jeux
magnifiques ballets puis dans son jeu
fait il a porté pour les cochons et puis
la soupe pour les patrons j'ai pas deux
pieds dans le même sabot qui est la
vaillance plus qui leur lot la journée
n'est pas terminée
les artistes se retrouvent au milieu
d'un nouveau public des personnes âgées
qu'ils connaissent pour certains vous je
mets mon bonnet d'am dam dom robert et
c'est passe-t-il berry c'est au bio le
but c'est travailler avec les locaux et
d'ouvrir la maison de retraite sur
l'extérieur pour que nous résidons ne
soient pas coupés du meeting à avoir une
vie associative et locales parce qu'on a
la maison de retraite qu'on n'a plus le
droit de profiter de la vie de
l'extérieur une idée qui match pour tous
les réseaux et la castille spectateurs
souris petit à petit devienne interprète
tout le monde ce projet ça c'est
agréable vie d'avant d'autant qu'ils
nous chantent des chats sans camions il
n'a pas connu des chansons nouvelles
quoi et même les anciennes
on est content bien de ça dans mon pays
et paris toujours mon coeur et ma salle
est belle mais abobo gagner ceux qui
bossent forfait c'est paris des
souvenirs dans les yeux dans les têtes
et des histoires à se raconter un
kilomètre de là au restaurant la forge
des petites mains s'activent pour
nourrir tous les participants de cette
26e édition delà du temps
au départ c'est déjà des menus compte
que j'ai établi d'avancé je travaille
qu'avec des produits de la région de la
région attention je m'entends philippe
qui est bouché à lignières fournit toute
la viande
je commande mais fruits et légumes
auprès de la petite épicerie de
lignières et
et j'essaye voilà de faire un petit peu
de plats de la région mais après il ya
un budget à respecter dont on fait ce
qu'on peut en fait c'est le choix du
festival de faire des circuits courts et
de développer le commerce local avec
devrait retomber les bains douches
savent très bien faire travailler tous
les commerçants locaux
qu'est ce que j'achète tout localement
déjà eu d'une part et en plus les gens
qui viennent au spectacle consomment sur
lignières donc c'est sûr que again
dablement il ya des retombées
économiques pour la commune des
commerçants qui s'investissent et qui
investissent ici
isabelle a acheté cette petite
camionnette pour l'air du temps et ses
prestations extérieures au final quand
il mange bien les festivaliers sont
ravis soit quelqu'un du coin qui face à
manger c'est une logique
ici il ya des artistes qui viennent de
loin mais c'est normal
une vraie qualité de vie pour tous les
participants
c'est une colonie de vacances j'ai
l'impression d'être un peu à la maison
ce que j'y suis venu plusieurs fois
c'est vraiment une équipe en tout cas
qui m'a accueilli et qui m'accompagne
depuis père longtemps donc venir à l'air
du temps c'est un rendez vous je dirais
régulier qui ponctue un peu comme ça ma
carrière je prends toujours beaucoup de
plaisir à être là et on mange très bien
tout devient possible grâce à une
cinquantaine de bénévoles
même si pour certains à première vue la
donne est un peu différente
[Musique]
c'est retrouver des gens qu'on voit que
ici c'est une ambiance qui avec eux ici
c'est bon ça c'est génial
gabriel saglio mélange ses rythmes afros
et latinos sous les yeux de cathy
l'aquarelliste qui dépendent toutes les
scènes
[Musique]
j'ai parcouru tout le pays
je ne te confier par le 10 centimes
grâce c'est une trace
deux rapports humains en fait c'est
vraiment
d'une part trace de l'artiste mais des
fois je raconte les spectateurs
d'effacer les spectateurs sont racontées
en 4 mm et 3 traite et ils sont heureux
d'être sur des saints c'est un festival
les rennais qui veut garder aussi toutes
ces phases-là avec affection et émotion
les spectacles se déroulent sous la
halle mais aussi aux manèges et ce soir
là c'est françois morel non si vous êtes
assez passionné vous faites avec today
avec tous les artistes ont lavé j'essaie
de les inscrire autrement dans le lieu
dans un premier temps il doit passer
devant l'objectif de yannick un exercice
particulier le photographe vérifions
tire le portrait des artistes depuis
maintenant 10 ans c'est un acte de
photographique sur une image donc
vraiment arriver à ce qui se passe
quelque chose dans 5 minutes et il se
passe quand même souvent quelque chose
c'est avec le lieu le l'artiste arrive à
prendre possession du lieu dans la
composition dans les changes avec
l'artiste et de l'artiste prenant
possession du lieu dont peu comme une
petite scène que je lui propose
voilà on joue en fait on joue à ce qu'un
petit jeu un jeu d'image de moments
servant de mémoire où le temps s'arrête
le temps qu'est ce qu'elles m'ont
[Musique]
soutenu
excusez moi mais c'est pas possible
comment l'enfant on démarre pas un
spectacle par une imitation
je pense qu'on doit avoir des passions
communes et j'espère qu'on on a tous
envie de passer une belle soirée ce soir
est de laisser des beaux souvenirs dans
la tête des spectateurs qui viendront ce
soir donc on a on est ensemble le même
projet je ne sais plus trop qui a dit
elle est pas belle la vie
il faisait chaud resteront
le soleil ce grand salon
vous faisait suer dégouliner
on était tous des ratés à côté des stars
sous ce soleil de plomb des jeunes
pousses pour noël viennent colorer le
parc des bains douches d'harmoniques
alpine venus d'ailleurs il s'appelle
facteurs chevaux
[Musique]
quand
ces nouveaux talents font le plaisir
d'un groupe d'amis ils se sont
rencontrés grâce au festival berrichon
je courais
[Musique]
on était plusieurs qu'on se connaissait
pas on a commencé à se voir une fois où
doit se dire bonjour puis à la parler
puis à voir qu'on avait des points
communs parce que la chanson c'est
souvent aussi des points communs
socialement politiquement que c est donc
on se retrouve maintenant régulièrement
le concert à peine terminée c'est
l'heure de la mise en page pour l'équipe
de reporter le journal gratuit du
festival une équipe amateur de
passionnés qui sillonnent lignières et
se retrouvent pour la correction avant
la pression pendant ces trois jours là
on essaye d'être des témoins les
passeurs de ce qui se passe ici à l'air
du temps
une belle aventure ça oblige à regarder
les concerts d'une manière un petit peu
différents candidats
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que je veux que
les spectateurs qu'ils soient qu'ils ont
vues soit qu'ils n'ont pas vu le
spectacle retiennent donc voilà ça c'est
un bon exercice
un exercice sur les plus jeunes comme
kim dope précède
matin et soir soir et matin change de
vagues on change de train sans entrain
pour assurer mon train train quotidien
toujours cette idée d'échangé de
transmission et ça j'aime assez et ça me
touche beaucoup d'être d'être là
aujourd'hui en plus d'ouvrir la soirée
avec thomas fersen c'est assez amusant
parce que c'est le l'artiste c'est le
premier artiste que j'ai vu en concert
de ma vie c'était à la cigale j'étais
tout petit et voilà donc là je me
retrouve avec lui sur sur une date
c'est chouette je faisais de tête
les douze coups de minuit j'ai repris du
poil de la bête
j'ai déterré pas vite garçons mater
était légère du ukulélé la guitare il
n'y a qu'une note autour d'une table un
boeuf s'improvise entre plusieurs
artistes de la grande famille de
lignières les chansons en hommage à
jean-claude marché le directeur du
festival qui prend sa retraite cette
année
[Musique]
c'est aussi ça l'air du temps de la
création de l'émotion le tout posé sur
une partition